stop it play physical play tough compete
boy Russell was playing with his food
for a long time and finally fired and
connected he's got 13.
and the lead back up to 19 points for
the Lakers full court pressure by
Vanderbilt on Moran
have to do it without Dylan Brooks the
rest of the way
[Applause]
into the corner Roddy
Tillman back out to jaw with nine on the
shot clock
John lost it in traffic and back the
other way three on one LeBron taking
flight oh set it with his chest timeout
Memphis
flight six ready for takeoff
the man who is number one across points
games minutes in the playoffs it's here
20.
he doesn't look like a mark oh come on
[Music]